hmm
okay we better just give it to
one more minute then and we better stick
to the rules
uh
okay i think we're on time aren't we
john
yeah you make it two o'clock okay okay
thanks uh everybody for tuning up on
time it's really
that's really wonderful and good
afternoon everybody who's watching us on
youtube hope you have
enjoyed have a nice day and enjoy our
meeting
okay so you all know why we're here
um i'll go through the agenda
and the first one on the agenda is
apologies for absence
sandra no no apologies sure i have no
apologies
great okay just apology chair just
apologies from david hayes
oh so okay yeah are you if we if we need
any
questions about uh if there's any
questions about that steve you gonna
answer them
i will share yeah okay
that chair yes cancel the leather
i don't know if i missed it perhaps
before you started but i'm substituting
for cattle manly
so i i assume she's giving her are you
substituting for
councillor manley okay fine okay
and i assume she's giving her apologies
she said she nobody's given
any apologies sandra i've not received
an apology from councillor manly chair
okay okay so we accept
council later and substitute okay
thank you yeah
item three declarations of interest you
all understand about the declarations of
interest so i don't need to
repeat all that you've missed public
contributions oh sorry uh
public contributions have we got any
members of the public
no no chair okay
thanks andre okay declarations of
interest
i've just spoke to you about
declarations of interest
agent matters brought up with the
permission of the chair i've got no
agent matters
uh agreement of agenda items part one
and two
we have got no part two so we go
straight
on to item number six calling temporary
free car cut parking
pages three to sixteen to receive the
report of the planning
economy manager and where is it is there
okay sean thank you chair
flying through the agenda today um so
that the report in front of you
outlines the discussions that we've had
to date
about free car parking members of course
be aware that
um on the 17th of august community
resources committee debated
council magos notice of motion that sat
in the report there
and made the decision that two hours
free parking at any time during the day
in all the car parks and biddeford holes
with the torrenting town centers for the
months
of october and november be agreed
subsequently that
that decision has been called to you
obviously
and what we've tried to do is provide
you with the information to facilitate
your debate
within the report so the table you have
on page four
report page four gives you the
uh figures the the income received from
each of those car parks identified last
year
so in a previous report uh we'd
estimated based on an average over six
months
we thought because we now know that the
specified months of october and november
have been named we were able to call
that so that gives you a figure there
to work with what david did before he
went on leave was also
trying to provide for you within the
report some ideas of how that might
be funded and so the report gives you
a couple of options uh on how you might
fund that free parking um repurposing of
some of the funds that we distributed to
the community
for the covid response is one one option
and there's also the option of uh
looking at you
repurposing the funding that you've or
cnr has previously set aside
for uh the appointment of four
apprenticeships
so uh those are things that you can
consider
um basically i don't think there's much
merit in going over the what's wise and
wherefores of free car parking again
that that isn't the subject of the
calling the decision is the subject of
the calling
there's been a lot of debate on that um
and i think pretty much i don't have
that much
extra to add chair but of course myself
and steve and stacy are here if you
uh need our assistance in your debate
okay
thank you sean okay i'll
throw it open to the rest of the
committee who wants to start
chancellor inch has got his hand up
chair sorry i i have
i've i've been joined in as host
john because i can't yes chad yes chad
have you got the participants
up and are you at the top of the list
yes fine got it now
um cancer lynch tony
thank you chair um just a couple of
questions really
if i may do you want me to go through
all the questions and then
get the officers to answer them yeah if
that's by my officers yeah
yeah okay well the first one is um that
those figures on page four um i
can only speak about the biddeford ones
really
but the bridge street river riverbank
short stay in the manor
that would be the bulk of the um
of the money we take in from those car
parks i
i imagine because they're all short stay
and uh
probably the bulk of people only parked
there for two hours so
that's going to um uh that would be the
bulk of the
the money coming into those car
or so our income i should think
on them on those car parks and
the other thing is as well is um
i don't know how tdc are going to
enforce
are able to enforce this uh two hours
for any
any time in all our car parks
um and i believe i'm right in saying
that we haven't got the
capacity i.e enforcement officers
to cover this because they'd have to go
around
through every car park and check them
every two hours so
i don't think we've got the capacity
there for one thing
and surely it would be better to to
manage this
with a set times uh two hours in the
morning or
or or even at the end of the day um
and the other question i think is for
stacey really is the equality and
diversity
um could this decision that
we're going to make today or they've
made with cnr
be challenged because this free park
car parking is it for the car
or is it for the taxpayer in the car
that could make a big
difference because i for instance i
could park
my car outside my house in bridge spring
street
from eight o'clock till 10 o'clock and
then
as i sometimes do not very often because
i leave it to other
people but um i go i could go and pick
up my mum
all right and bring her back into town
to do some shopping
who who who is the taxpayer for
torridge now does she get free parking
as well as i did in the morning
and and also does my wife get free park
car parking because she's a taxpayer as
well so
i think this could be challenged in some
way in
if somebody wanted to they could
challenge tdc
on that because um as i say is
is the free car parking for the car or
is it for the taxpayer
in the car that's the only thing i'd
like to say
chair i did sit in i did sit in at the
meeting
when seeing or had i didn't say very
much i didn't say anything at all
actually
but i just i just thought that um
in a way that um councilors didn't
sort of um comment very much or
take any much notice of the report
written by the officer and i thought
they were
they were um their heart was ruining
their head at that time
but that's the only thing i'd expect to
say um
chair if i could have the answers thank
you okay thank you
tony uh okay sean would
be the best place to answer those okay
yeah it's chair i mean it i think that
coming back on the first point in terms
of income
the lion's share of all of our pay and
display income is on the first two hours
of our of parking
so you know in in the past we've done an
analysis since roughly two thirds of the
you're paying display income
is is derived in the first two hours of
people parking in our cargo so
i suppose there's a fairly accurate
point there that
most of your income in those car parks
will be um given up
um capacity for staffing i i'm
i mean any parking initiative is going
to have people who
try to abuse it as there are people who
try to abuse the current controls we
have
in place we have four enforcement
officers
around our car parks and they travel
between the car parks and it
you know it's perfectly possible that
somebody could
go into one car park i should probably
explain the process that they would need
to follow
so they come into a car park they walk
up to a machine
they go to they input their registration
number they
select a zero pounds tariff and then
that will give them to entitle them to
two hours free parking so
if the the time of issue will go on the
ticket the display the ticket
and somebody will come around and see
that they've got the two hours parking
if it exceeds that we would issue a pcn
if they were caught by our enforcement
officers it is perf
it is possible i don't know how likely
it be but it is possible that somebody
could
drive to multiple car parks within the
district
from eight till ten drop move on to the
next one from ten to twelve the next one
and we wouldn't catch up with them so
you technically could have free parking
all day
and unless somebody is obviously parking
unsafely or they've got a most unusual
car
um our uh enforcement officers are
unlikely to notice
that uh somebody was doing or abusing
the the offer like that but again i i
can't comment on how like that is
because that would be
that would be guesswork in terms of
equality for user i suppose that
it pretty much the same
point because i i think if you come if
what we don't know who's in the car so i
don't know if councillor inches
mother-in-law
is is is in the car and she's entitled
to it
we would have to go on the car so it's
the car registration that we'll be
monitoring
so technically i guess it's the driver
of the car that's
benefiting from the discretionary free
parking
right okay thanks sean uh tony
are you happy with that
oh yeah yes sir i mean uh but i
can can stacy just that shouldn't we
just ask here see if that
could be challenging the court at all
um chair probably stacy's better that
it's better to understand it
it depends if somebody were to challenge
you we'd have to consider that
um station whether
you've got any kind of views on that
um thank you um i think councillor inch
we're open to challenge on any
decision that we make could someone
challenge us
yes is it a valid challenge i don't know
it really depends
upon the decision that's been going to
be made um
and that the full circumstances of it
but you know equally
there's never never anything to stop any
of our
decisions being challenged so i think
it's hard to kind of comment without
knowing the pacific
circumstances and and what members are
are going to
agree i mean i
would it be one that i don't think it
would be one easily challengeable i
think
on this that the major challenge may be
the financial side of it as opposed to
equality
in terms of um who gets the free
car parking
all right thanks stacy right who's next
anybody else got any questions okay you
got councillor leather with his hand up
oh sorry yes chris
oh me chris i'm just trying to thanks
shay yeah
well i thought the original decision at
cnr to give two hours
any time of the day was a ridiculous
decision to take
because i think as shaun has said the
majority of tickets that
parking tickets are for one to two hours
that's the majority of parking tickets
that
now what they decided to see in our two
hours anytime during the day
that means anybody most people will be
parking for nothing most people will be
parking for
nothing because they'll come in and the
majority park for one to two hours and
they'll be gone again
so i thought it was ludicrous that to
make it any time in the day
and i i'm a bit i'm a bit um
flummoxed with these gr with these
graphs showing the car parking
the amount of money collected on page
nine you've got the top
graph there that shows the cost of free
parking
until nine or until 10. so
are we really saying that on those car
parks up to 10 o'clock
every day we take nearly 25
600 pounds up to 10 o'clock on those car
parks every day
in october and in november that's one
question
if that's true if that and looking at
the one on page four
i didn't quite understand that must be
the total income for
october and november shown there for the
whole month i think
which we wouldn't receive which we
wouldn't receive well
yeah you would that's as i read that and
sean would have to answer this
on page four sean you show the october
income for the car parks and the
november income
is that the total income for each for
the months from those car parks
yeah yes yes it is so it's not the two
it's not just the two hours on each day
it's the total
two-hour tariff income for or up to two
hour
income for the month right so that could
be any time during the day
that could come yes that's right
right so just looking at bridge street
car park
then which page are you on chris on page
four
at the top bridge street shows total
income of thirteen thousand nine hundred
yeah on page nine then it shows bridge
street
up till ten o'clock three thousand nine
hundred more or less
so the rest of the day
are we saying then normally you take i
am confused with these figures i really
am
but i mean what i what i would propose
what i would propose
is that we because i'm pretty sure
everybody wants the two hours
parking to show support for the
businesses make
i should i would think we should stop
charging at four o'clock in the
afternoon would be best especially as
sean has just said
two-thirds of the income is in the first
two hours every day
so you know i don't think we can afford
to lose two-thirds of our car park
income
in the first two hours if we made it
until
four o'clock and then the two hours is
from four to six free
but i'll be interested to hear the
contributions to her
yeah but but i am confused with some of
these figures i gotta admit
might be worth someone explaining the
two the two tables are two different
things
i think the table comes to leather's
referring to on page
nine was before we had an absolute
decision to consider
um so that was averaging over a period
of time
and uh free parking up to those
um time stipulations in the day
uh whereas uh when the decision was
reached at cnr
it was more precise in terms of two
hours
any time for two particular months so uh
sean
and the team were able to specifically
identify
the more actual data that was included
on page
nine so that's so the figures are not
comparable okay thanks steve
chris did you understand that
not really sure no but anyway i'll hear
what everybody else has to say
okay okay right uh
simon you're on next
simon i'm mute i am indeed
uh thank you uh chair uh i'm gonna
actually push this back to you slightly
to start with because there's a shortage
of questions
uh and i think chair you were the one
who called this
in yeah and to my knowledge yours is the
only name on the call-in document
so perhaps you could uh start with the
questions
that you had because obviously you've
got the concern because you put you
called it in
fine yeah my concern my concerns are
that
i don't think this council can afford to
do it
for a start uh we will
if we if we implement this central
government will give us none of the
money back
and i'm not that convinced that we
actually
really need free parking
um i i i i've made one or two visits to
one or two of the of the um
car parks especially the one in olds
where they
i went up there two two when uh not a
week week as this last wednesday
and the mana park car park was full
i just managed to get a space
at 11 o'clock in the morning and
actually i put my 30p
in so i had to walk into the square
to find out where all the people were at
whether they were at the market because
it's market day
and there was hardly anybody there so
where are all the people
that are that are filling the mana car
park up
and it did so to me it won't matter
anything i was going to say a damn that
that
we haven't got free parking because
they'll still use the mana car park
and and let's face it you can park there
for two hours
for one pound 20. so
what what i don't see the problem if you
if you run a car and
you can afford a car surely you can
afford one pound 20.
so that's one of the reasons i called it
in and then and
i just don't
quite a few times sean carney has been
back to us
at ons and proved that it doesn't
increase footfall
well okay i'm inclined to agree with him
because
at one ons meeting tony tony inch put
forward to him about doing a survey on
one of the car parks
if i'm correct me if i'm wrong i can't
quite remember which car park it is tony
but if you want to unmute and tell me
that's fine
um and sean did it and proved it that
it was no good it was a waste of time
and
on top of that when you look at the
shopping
habits of people now as to
i'll give you i'll give you some figures
77 and this comes from not from me
this
or other grocery shoppings in line
compared to 61
this time last year yeah
sorry jay you froze through half of that
so we've got two
um shopping habits so you might all
right sorry
sorry about that i'm glad you're in
stacy
yeah to pull me up um
yes okay the shopping habits of people
uh this is from supermarkets
and they have found that 77
of customers right shop online for
groceries
now as opposed to 61
this time last year and and one in four
brits
shop online for groceries at least once
a week
and unless the and over 55
now um
a shop there's 74 percent of them
shopping online
for groceries i mean how can we i can we
as a council look at look at
losing this money okay not probably it's
not spending it
but looking at losing it when we've got
these sort of figures where
where people are shopping online even
aldi this week
is is going to start click and collect
you know that means a customer doesn't
have to walk around the store
you know and and i'd like to council
mcguffie
demo yeah um
you leave a comment you made a comment
if if we put this money out
we will get it back tenfold now could
you explain
how we get it back tenfold
okay right i said if we support the
local businesses
and obviously residents within the town
centers
uh we would get back to info because the
idea is to encourage people back into
the town centers to spend
money that they obviously keep the money
in a local economy which the local
economy then
benefits from it now i i dressed under
the covered point that you mentioned we
never mentioned covered actually people
are shopping online but that's due to
cobit
we're all aware of this at the moment
and unfortunately some of the way the
media swings at the moment with the
uncertainty at the times that's why
online shopping has gone up the idea is
to get
footfall back in the town centers with
the regeneration projects of
benefit high street funding our high
streets to dying
we've got to try and do something to try
and um
revitalize these town centers now the
initiative free car parking
was to try and give these energy shop
owners and business people
in the towns they pay the rates it comes
back to the district council
to reduce a receipt like that we're not
going to lose 70 thousand pounds
because these are figures that are based
on previous years
not due on the covered figures that are
due i give you the point that the
government wouldn't support the money
free car parking but as an authority
we find money for the slipway westwood
home
for the art center the burton art centre
the plow art center
or well-worthy causes but that only
this is for your equality and diversity
that only touches a small percentage of
the population within toric
some people may not even like arts or
culture that's that's a society in
general
you know so um saying about the
diversity that inequality there
that could answer that question it's for
some and not for others but
one point it counts as a wrench i like
to touch on you know and
i've got to say that i don't know i
think he's having a funny moment to be
honest
saying about car parking it was two
hours car parking
per day per car limited to only one car
and if you got 10 even if you rammed up
10 people in the car
it's put it's irrelevant you that one
car registration that car pays
that pays the tab on it now other people
walk in you don't walk in the car but
get a ticket and slap it on yourself
dude you put it in your car
so i i just didn't i don't know where
it's coming from catches the levers
thing
ludicrous well you're entitled to your
opinion no problem
there at all but after four o'clock most
your shops close that forum benefit
unfortunately
so what you're going to give you're
getting enough about the town centres to
limit a time between eight or ten in the
morning
that would only benefit people who live
in the town centre itself
who could then use a get out of bed and
maybe have if you're working late at
actually a couple of
a couple of hours but then you would get
congestion within the car parks
where you get a mass mass pilot of
people trying to get into a car park
because you've got a limited hour of two
hours without the day
it gives us a general sense of people
coming into
general football coming in and then over
the course of the day
we generate money coming into sound
centers i'm happy to say someone a
miniature
this has been tried before
and it doesn't prove that it increases
footfall
i mean where chair where's the proof
it's been tried before
there is no approach that's been tried
before free trial
two-month trial for the public and the
business owns inventory it's three
months
so we can actually ask a team whether it
works or not i mean for me
my idea of free car parking was to try
and benefit the business community and
in residence trying to give something
back
we're great at collecting money in
storage but we're great at cutting the
services within torridge
and what are what the public getting for
it not a lot well but eventually
the services might have to be cut so we
just don't know where that's going
anyway but but i
i totally disagree with you uh you know
i think two hours
two hours free parking probably on
maybe on on a saturday why not give it
why not give them the
the parking on the saturday while most
people go shopping
ask him where the proof is yeah can i
come back to the beast
yeah you could come back yeah but i are
you my
question no but first of all i'm not
gonna interrupt
your statement that was if we
if we put this money out
we will get it back tenfold now
we are the council so tenfold to me
on on 72 let's take it on 72
000 is getting back 720
000 pounds now where do we get that back
from them
thank you much i'll answer that chair
i'm elected
member by the residents within torridge
therefore i represent the elected
members first before i represent this
authority
i'm sorry many people who put it ticks
you are a district councillor the first
priority is to the district
not not my first priority chair is to
the residents of entourage who like to
be into my position
okay you don't tell me my priorities i
know my priorities
where is your proof that this won't work
you have no proof you're merely
speculating
i missed that anyway i'm frozen but
anyway
anyway where is your proof that this
will not work
i'm going to move on
all right mate councillor cottle hunking
where
are you thank you um i
support the decision made by cnr for two
hours
two three hours anytime through october
and november
however it's unfair to suggest that the
council would lose 72
000 from offering two hours free parking
this year
these figures are based on last year
pre-covered
yes we may have seen an increase in
tourists over the summer
but through october and november the
children will be back at school
and there's also the threat of the
second wave of the virus
and any associated lockdowns and
anxieties that would bring
we're already seeing increases in the
virus down in torridge
prior to the summer holidays the
quarterly business report
admitted a reduction in footfall in town
centres as a behaviour change
and sean carney admitted in a previous
report on car parking
that the actual figures are hard to
predict and even in this report has
stated that consumer behavior is
difficult to predict
the leader of the council also gave in
his reasoning for some free
parking that he believed the takings
would be much lower
than the amount quoted in the report
therefore to ask councillors to find
such a sum as inaccurate and wrong
we should also recognize in our
strategic plan our vision to support a
thriving economy
which is the aim of this notice of
motion
it's not a huge amount to ask it's only
for two months to help businesses during
what's an extremely difficult time
it needs to be heavily advertised and i
would hope that it will encourage local
people
to venture into their town centres
rather than simply bypassing it for the
super stores or online shop
online shopping and hopefully they will
rediscover
the great local products and services
that are available on their doorstep
and will be encouraged to visit again in
the future when parking charges are
reinstated
we need to show support for our local
businesses and town centres
by supporting this motion it could be
the difference between whether some of
our independent traders come out of the
other side of this or not
which will have a knock-on effect on the
whole community
thank you okay um chair
sean kearney's got his hand up i don't
know if you want to ask let him in
at this point because he may be
responding to some of the earlier
questions i'll put i'll put you in next
shot
thank you yeah just to pick up on a
couple of points that were made there
um so we haven't uh previously tried the
two hours
free parking we haven't trialled that we
have trialled
free parking on the pill um so the pill
in biddeford
uh there's been free parking and if you
recall councillor christie
often comments that that hasn't
necessarily been the success it was
going to be but that
to put it into context we haven't
trialled
what's proposed here today okay so
so you know we have we all have opinions
on whether we think free parking
is the way to stimulate activity
footfall in town centers or not
um we haven't trialled that by trying
free parking in the past so that's
that's the first point
the the coming back to councillor cottle
hankins um last comments there
um i there's certainly no intention to
mislead members by
inflating figures that we don't think
are reasonable those are actual figures
from last year
and they're the best we can do in an in
a guesstimate
of what we're talking around cost wise
this year
so um we know we are where we are in
terms of decision from our point of view
uh members have debated this at
community resources and resolved
something
we know we now try to implement that for
you
and in doing that we're proposing
solutions for how you might
fund what we estimate might be the cost
for it
so it's is it's far from us trying to
put barriers
in the way by inflating figures is
trying to propose a solution for you
to implement what you've resolved to cnr
thanks sean shirley
thank you um i i have to say i feel very
torn about this um and i'm very
interested to hear what is said
this afternoon um a bit like
um you chair my gut feeling
is that i don't think it will increase
football in the town centers
i i don't think it will um
i haven't any evidence for that um but i
just
i don't think it has that major in
effect however
and it does really worry me the amount
of money potentially
uh the council could lose from it
however
i have to say i you know i have great
respect for other councillors strong
health
views genuinely health views and also
the views of the traders and those who
represent them and to a certain extent
you could argue that anything um that
will lift morale or anything that could
help slightly would be
a good thing and i was particularly
impressed at cnr by
the amount of communication from
torrington people about how strongly
they felt about it
um i mean this will be a bit of a red
herring but
my feeling is that in some ways the
money that
could go to offset this in some ways
would be much better if it was used
for something to stimulate people going
into town in a different way like
staging events but obviously that's a
red herring at the moment because that
can't happen because of the pandemic
but it's something to think about for
the future
and i would feel happier i suppose i'm
sort of sitting on the fence here a
little bit but i would feel happier
if it was just biddeford in november
so we still get any possible i know this
may not happen because of a future
lockdown or whatever but
um you would still get any half-term
tourist traffic coming into biddeford
but if it was benefited in november
and torrington and holsworthy for
october and november
um because then it would reduce the
amount of loss to the council
um i have to you know i i'm
i am undecided in terms of where the
money comes from
can i just ask sean one question in what
you said at the beginning of the meeting
sean
um i thought you said it could come from
the apprentices
or it could come potential one
suggestion was that it would come from
well in in the documentation it said the
member community grant funding but i
thought you made
some reference to um funding for covid19
interventions
have i misunderstood that thank you john
would you come back and answer that
you want me to answer the the finance
page okay yeah
okay steve so as council langford
pointed out on on page five of your
report
um that sets out the the options that
david hayes
has put forward for members to consider
how uh should this go forward how it
could be defended
and to cast our minds back um to the
start of
the pandemic um a decision was
taken um to catch half of the member
grants for this current financial year
ie 36 000 to use
towards providing funding for the the
community
resource so providing money through to
parish and town councils to help
with those the community side of things
home deliveries and things
so in that so that's included at the top
of that table on the top of page five
and there's a couple of other things
that went into producing a
a resource to do that to balance of
member grants from the previous year
some brought forward new homes bonus
at the moment you'll see the bottom half
of that table identifies
what's been expended from that
pot of money and the indication there
although one figure has yet to be
finally confirmed that there's a balance
available of 93
000 so members could
take the 72 000 out of that 90 93
000 funded the other alternative that's
been put forward
is that 51 000 pounds being set aside
in this year's uh budget
to further um recruit
some apprentices and the suggestion is
also if you don't want to use the 91 000
the 93
000 that we decide or members consider
not recruiting apprentices and use that
51
000 towards it so they are the options
they are the options that are available
within
the budget anything outside of the
budget
would need further consideration so if
you
recall the original notice of motion
what
did indicate looking at a number of
different options
uh looking at the capital program for
example now as members are aware our
capital program
is currently over committed so that
would
require a lot more work to do and to
review and members to consider
as opposed to something that members
could
consider not doing to fund
the cost of this so originally we
suggested that if the member grants
the top slice wasn't used for the
community response
that would go back into the member
grant's budget
and be used so bringing your 1 000 pound
per member back up to 2 000 pounds
remember
that's fine hopefully uh that makes uh
makes it a little bit clearer
yeah thank you thanks steve
right um ian oppa where are you
hello right i've heard about the
business about
free parking i try to look on the net
and find any research on it
there's no absolutely no research
whatsoever done on free parking
however in march 2015 the welsh
government
a report produced by mr uk clearly that
said
that free parking doesn't actually work
youth forward
sorry yorkshire forward says no parking
uh free parking is not working but what
is an offer is what people come into
town for
on the research they found the vast
majority of people actually come into
town
not for shopping but for personal
business and
appointments the british parking
association
also put that tariffs
the cost is not the main main
worries that people have in parking is
location personal safety
and uh safe environment
so therefore in the same most of the
things we've got now at the moment is
anecdotal evidence nothing is actually
firm
however i would agree with council
leather that two hours
if you want to do that way is probably
the best way forward but perhaps the
longest term is
sure as council langford said is to work
with the um
chamber of commerce and actually develop
an offer
that works more effectively than just
offering free parking
thanks chair yeah thank you okay
uh nick laws
uh thank you chair um chair like a lot
of people i'm torn by this but i think
that
all the figures about free parking etc
they're one thing but what we're
actually trying to do
is to show our support to the residents
uh i think that as a piece of pr
it would be excellent i think the cost
is too
great sorry
sorry i think that the cost is uh um
too great but i agree with um
i agree with the proposals in some ways
but it's too expensive and i would
suggest that consideration is given
again
to just one parking ground
you see people would head for it and
we've got in biddeford
some large parking grounds so i mean if
we took
the pill or or main parking ground on
the front
and that was made you're then looking at
something around the figure of 10 or
eleven thousand
and one parking ground in each of the
other terms
or if there's two in holes worthy and
they feel
that they are sort of need more
consideration there
there's only one in all four
but the figure now is too high although
i
i applaud the chancellor mcgoff
for his spirit in in wanting to support
me
and that's what it's about supporting
people not necessarily the finances
thank you chair yeah nick there there is
only one in oldsworthy
the welcome the well car park is a pound
a day so i can you give two hours free
okay anyway okay
sorry we'll give them all day yeah
that's fine
um simon
you're on
chair thanks um and thank you for
bringing forward your your reasons for
the calling in the first place i i
didn't mean to
try to put you on the spot as such but
but you were
you were asking for questions and it
didn't seem that you were the first one
to
to to put those forward if i could just
if i could just summarize
my personal view and then end with a
proposal which
may help um i've never
been keen on this measure
and like many people i i doubt its
effectiveness
however i do appreciate it as a gesture
as a short-measured gesture in the covid
crisis
and i also accept the fact that full
council have sent it
twice in principle to cnr and cnr
have debated it twice and that i
accept the view of other councillors
i'm concerned that some councillors
who are known to have been long-term
activist
in trying to secure free permanent
free car parking in some of our town
centres
are actually using this or are hoping to
use this
as a back door way of getting
longer-term free car parking
in our town centers and i remind
ourselves that car parking
equates to a third of our self-generated
income
so we generate three million pounds
within ourselves
within the council and car parking
equates roughly to a million of it a
year
so you know we are dealing with a key
income resource when things are tight
um i'm a little concerned about
the emotional options that officers have
put up as to how we might fund it
um councillor grants
is designed to make us feel
uncomfortable and apprenticeship
apprentice
threatening the apprentice program
likewise
um is meant to make everybody go a bit
wobbly as well
there are other areas where we could
look for it because there are
i know budget variances from from what
we've planned
although it look it requires us to look
outside the budget but that's more
more effort i am concerned
overall as to the affordability of it
but also the need to
make this gesture work and the strength
of feeling
and indeed the number of times
that counselors of a majority have
actually
said look at this and see if you can
make it work
and i do accept that in our debates
that we've had and i can't remember
whether it was one of the full council
debates or whether it was in cnr
one of the points that was made was that
the
impact of covid amongst other things it
creates delay
when people are in the town centers to
go shopping it takes longer because you
have to queue
or you can only have three in a shop or
whatever it is
and therefore there was people were
running out or risked
running out of time on their their
parking etc
if we're looking at something that
genuinely
might create some relief to that
pressure
and also satisfy the gesture requirement
but also perhaps makes it more
affordable
perhaps we should look at offering the
second hour
free buy one get one free
so everybody buys their first hour but
they automatically in fact
get a two hour ticket so therefore we're
giving people
more time in other words to nullify the
impact of covid when shopping so it's
more justifiable perhaps
and also actually we will continue to
recover
probably what is the land share of of of
the income which is the first hour
parking
um that is uh a proposal that uh
i've only really recently sort of
realized ticked
several of the boxes and may um
be a way forward perhaps thank you chad
thank you
can you just come out back and answer
that sean
it could that be implemented uh chair
yes
that's that's possible that's uh it
it again we're going to remember that if
we we're setting things in
in place for a longer term then we'd
need to change to the parking order
but as a temporary measure um in essence
offering a three hours parking so by
your first hour get your second hour
free
is possible for us to manage this i mean
just going back to simon before simon do
you mean
just for the first hour not rolling
hours
no no what i'm saying is that you you
if you you get your second hour
free if you only go and buy an hour
you in fact get a ticket that lasts for
two hours
yeah if you buy a ticket that that's for
longer
then that the second hour is still free
somehow it's computed into that so say
that you're still getting
that second hour for free um
but yes that most of the most of the
revenue comes from within the first two
hours
and in fact probably comes within the
first hour but i think
the the the the the gesture side could
be there as a second hour and
and it you know theoretically people
have said that they're under pressure
because of covid restrictions well
that's perhaps a way of reducing the
pressure logically
okay thanks simon
cheryl
um i was just wondering and there was a
comment made at cnr
about not all of the biddeford car parks
being shoppers car parks
so and there are a large number of car
parks in bedford
whether we were to reduce the biddeford
car parks the main shopping runs which i
guess
are bridge street and the pill then that
would reduce if you added all of those
up
that would bring it to 45 000 which is
significantly lower than 72
and especially if we think that actually
it probably won't be that much money
that we'd lose anyway because it's a
covered year and not a pre-covered year
then that would be a lot lower i would
propose that we
reduced the number of car parks in
biddeford so what you're saying cheryl
is that in biddeford it would just be
bridge street and the pill
is that what sean carney would suggest
as being the top
shoppers car parks
this is for buy one get one free no
just for the two hours at any time
right okay
the same as what cnr had said but it
would just reduce the number of car
parks it's applicable to so it supports
the town center
shopping not not all of the car parks
in germany i'm inclined to agree with
that sean
can you answer it yeah yeah yes of
course yeah i mean
yes i'd agree that probably our main uh
shoppers car parks are bridge street
river branch shore state the manor
the pill and the key having said that
there's
there's an element of shoppers car park
about homestone street in support of the
pannier market operation
um so so that you might want to bear
that in mind
clarence wharf is east of water the
other side of the bridge
is more a residence parking space
actually
very popular with uh commuters to the
town who park there and work and tang
right um so yeah
the bridge street riverbank shortstay
the manor
the pill the key certainly
maybe homestead street
maybe what say it against the street is
the one that where people park to go to
the pannie market
okay okay right
move on then chris leather
thank you chair well it's been
interesting listening to the various
suggestions and
and the debate in general i'm still at
the view that to allow two hours
any time of the day is too too expensive
we'll lose
a huge amount of income and that's where
that for the two months of october and
november that's where the 72
400 pounds comes in because that is
for tickets for up to two hours for
those two months last year
there are a lot of people about now that
i don't accept that
the number of visitors will drop off in
october and november i think it'll stay
very high because
people are not taking foreign holidays
and there are a lot of visits about
still and a lot of people wait until
the children are back at school before
they come down here on holiday
and i think that's been increasing so i
really am against two hours any time of
the day we'd lose an awful lot of money
that way
yeah but it used to be and it's not that
many years ago that we used to only
charge
until four o'clock in an afternoon and
then there was
i don't know why it extended past that
but i do take
um i do disagree with councillor mcguff
i was in shopping in biddeford at
quarter past five
most shops are open the majority shops
are still open at five o'clock
gone half five is at what time most seem
to close
but i think if we granted two hours free
from four o'clock until six
for those two months and that be a good
trial period to see
two things whether it extends shopping
uh
past four o'clock and i believe it would
do or would
help it anyway uh
and also it's it's the gesture that
we've all wanted to show our support for
the
the businesses in the district that are
fighting to come back the
the particularly the small shopkeepers
so
you know i'd like to propose really that
we
we go from four to six o'clock free uh
for those two months and that we
report back to full council not to say
anymore are you are you
saying that for every car park in
biddeford
yeah all the car parks listed on page
four
yeah okay and i think that would be a
substantial reduction
it would be nothing like the 72 000
shown there
i doubt it would be half of that do you
want to make a comment on that sean
uh chair
i guess it would be a reduction i can't
i can't estimate for you what it would
be
in terms of reduction then one of the
comments that i've picked up on
going through this and there seems to be
some inference that this is a trial
for a and a longer lasting scheme and i
i'm not sure that that was
in it has been resolved on and and i do
have some concerns if people think that
that's what this is
because um making some assessments
i don't think we'll ever really
understand the success or otherwise of
this initiative
we don't it's a most unusual year
shopping practices is different
tourism is different everything is
different dwell times are different
um i i we don't really have the tools to
to to measure the the footfall
increase potential footfall increase of
this
so in using this data or using anything
from this
two months if we find a solution for it
would be a very worrying thing for me
okay well i'm not i'm not sure i'm not
suggesting
i might may have said it was a trial
well at least
it will give us the opportunity to get
some feedback from the businesses in the
towns
whether having free parking from four
till six
has affected their business and if
they've come back and say there's no
difference that's fine there's no
difference but the thing is as sean said
the the two-thirds of the bulk of this
one to two hours tickets
is in the first two hours of the day he
said between eight and ten o'clock
that is two-thirds of the income on up
to two hours
tickets so go to the end of the day from
four
not the end of the day four o'clock in
the afternoon isn't that late in the day
for me
so go to four from four till six bearing
in mind we only used to charge till four
on the car parks and that's that's that
gesture
aspect of it fulfilled and it'll also
give the
the businesses in the towns the chance
to come back and say well
whether it's made any difference to them
or not and it's only for two months
and after that after that if it's not
sure to be any kind of success it's not
helped in any way
it certainly wouldn't be repeated and
nobody'd be asking for it for it to be
repeated
or for any hours of our parking to be
changed to a permanent four o'clock
again you know
it's just for these two two uh months
october and november
but but it would be a substantial
reduction on the seventy two thousand
as i said two-thirds as sean said
two-thirds of the income
for two-hour tickets one to two hour
tickets is in the first two hours in the
day
so if it's a if it's a third of that i'd
be surprised
yeah i don't thanks for that chris uh
cheryl you're on again
thanks and i've got a question actually
about the resources it says are
available
it's got the new homes bonus brought
forward
from 2019. um i was told that there are
projects that still haven't heard back
from their applications for the new
homes bonus funding
and this is presumably due to long-term
staff sickness
and subsequent staff leaving um so i'd
like to see this money go back to those
projects that missed out
and three of those i believe are in
great torrington
so i don't think that this should be
available i think that
that funding should go to the projects
that haven't heard back and have
pretty much missed out on funding for
our local communities
and another question about the borough
center um
did we receive extra money from the
prime minister's bill bill build
incentive because i was under the
impression that we received quite a lot
of money for that which we weren't
expecting
and whether that would help um we won't
need to spend as much from our capital
funds if we've received that from the
central government
and maybe we consider that that extra
could go towards
two months of some free parking as a
gesture to our town centers
steve um on the first one um sean might
need to
answer the part about the the new homes
bonus funding
although we would have to reflect that
part of the the original
decision was taking that money um
out of new homes bonus to pay for the
the community
response in terms of the uh prime
minister's bill bill bill
yes um we're not we're fairly confident
we will have some extra money
all that hasn't been finally confirmed
yet uh we're waiting for
announcements uh from the lep
um and that will hopefully be soon
however as i indicated earlier the
capital program
is still overspent so any resources that
come back to the capital program
would need to be used to balance the
capital program
unless members start to consider taking
other projects out steve i think that's
it that's a completely different
exercise which we're just embarking
on now looking at next year's capital
program
steve cheryl
god i'm frozen i was i frozen then
chair you froze yesterday mentioned this
for this money coming back to 400 000
was that going to go to the boroughs
project then it was specific it was a
specific
application uh in relation to the
borough's project yes
right okay and if sean can answer the
bit on the
the new homes bonus grant please
okay so certainly um so so
as as i understand it i mean uh
councillor kosovanki makes a point
there that some of the projects that
were in the process of making
application to us
um hadn't received uh for any feedback
some of the projects hadn't actually
completed their application so they were
in the process of making application
their projects were slowly developing
and they never
got to the point of making full
application weren't assessed
and so after the financial year closed
and we said that last year was the last
financial year of the
of the new homes bonus scheme we closed
the new homes bonus scheme and that
money was then repurposed by ourselves
for support in our communities so there
are
a number of community groups out there
that had hoped to get
new homes bonus funding um
that haven't got new homes bonus funding
then they're not just in torrington
there are
others elsewhere um i guess that's a
decision
is whether you reinstate that for that
purpose or whether you
leave it for its existing purpose or
whether you use it for
um for paying for free car parking
initiatives i think that's entirely over
to
to you as counselors fine
peter ames oh thank you took so long to
get to you
that's right um yeah thank you chair
and it is a very difficult decision i
think and um
yeah i i welcome the debate that's gone
on so
a number of points which have been put
forward but i do tend to what you said
that
and to what um ian harper said that that
you know i'm not
not convinced there is the evidence that
charging that not
charging is going to make a huge amount
of difference to town
centers um and for a car owner i think
you know um a car parking charge is
quite especially the low fairly low
charges we have in our car parks it is
not a great consideration
um for um people coming in to shop
um the four to six idea i mean i don't
think
you know most people come in earlier
than that i think to shock but
i mean the big point i need i wish to
make is about climate change and
people are talking about a gesture
towards the
you know the shopkeepers and everything
but um you know
it's also by by saying that we're going
to make free parking it's also a gesture
that we're not
in a way committed to reducing car use
but
um people are going to use their cars
anyway
i think um they'll they'll pay for for
parking
and uh without any worries i think so
i'm i'm very uneasy about this uh
proposal i'm afraid
thank you catholic
leather come back
um just to remind everybody that of
course full council the majority of full
council
wanted to do something and that's why
this went to cnr
um the recommendations on page five chef
if somebody would second what i'd like
to propose
i'd like to propose that the two hours
uh excuse me chris the recommendation
recommendations on page six
sorry sorry i froze again god knows
what's happening to me
the recommendations where on page six
bottom of page six
oh thank you well i'd like to propose
that the first
a is that the two hours
free parking be restricted to the out
between the hours of four and six
o'clock
for october and november right on all
car parks listed
that the recommendation is taken to full
council not to cnr
and that the funding is a top slice from
members grants
which is 36 000 and i i think that would
be more
more than adequate to cover for that
period sean would have to
check that out but but chris chris
you talk about using the 36 000 from
last year yeah from members grants
there's not every ward that will see
benefit from free parking
well a lot of people come into the major
towns to shop at some time rather than
like that whether i doubt whether we're
talking about holes where they
sent giles broadwood widget or whatever
because it is not it's not worth them
going
well i'm not sure we're talking about
the top slice of 36 000
to pay for this
we've already give over to people
to to steve
just come back to you 36 000 was what we
took out of
council of grants yes yes that's that's
right
but on the team let's go back to the
table on page five
yeah um so we took 36 000
and those other sources of funding the
top three items
to produce a pot of money um to provide
the community response the bottom half
of the table is indicating how much of
that we
spent so of the 93
000 left we could reinstate the 36 000
pounds to member grants
but councillor leather's proposal which
again hasn't been seconded yet
um is to use the 30s to continue to use
so not to put the 36 back thousand back
to member grants
and to use that to fund this pro
this current proposal or council of
leathers proposal
i think that's how i understand it comes
together thank you
thank you steve that's that's it yeah
and i don't
i don't agree with that i can't agree
with that no but i don't i doubt it
would be 36 000 in any event
for that two-hour period in october and
november but sean had
sean carney would come back and give us
the full figures of that i prefer
i'd prefer it for for the for the new
homes bonus to go
to it sean
i've made a proposal chair i don't know
if anybody will second it or not
no i'd i'd second that proposal
uh council ever if if it wasn't to do
with
uh members grants
if it was if it was the if it was to
take it
from the next bearing in mind it's the
majority of members of full council
who wanted to do something along these
lines yeah i can't
i can't see that they're going to object
to some of that going towards this
these proposals but there we are okay
anyway you've got you've got two members
of the committee with their hands up so
whether that's in in indication of five
and councillor mcgoff i've got five
there is no yes yeah uh hang on one
minute did
did sean want to come back and just say
something
no not really sure i mean very quickly
uh i think probably councillor leather
is
is is accurate that it would be um quite
a lot
less than uh yeah okay
i don't have those figures with me okay
simon
just following up on what's just been
said um
of course another way of of looking at
the funding is that
you could fund this from the top slice
of the councillors involved in the towns
concerned
so it's actually their contribution to
their local businesses to help their
businesses
we out in the sticks we don't benefit
from this and we
we're quite sure that we don't benefit
from it um
and and therefore um
i wouldn't be happy that that um more
member grant
money is is spent in this way
from for instance my area because
actually that money to us
out in the sticks we can do a lot of
money we can do a lot with that money
and it and it's it's a a very key
engagement tool um the
but if that's the case if if that's the
way people want to go then why don't the
town councillors or the
the councillors representing town
wards which are affected they um
actually use some of their grant in
effect
to fund this because it's directly
applicable to the businesses in their
towns
um so that may make it more direct uh
and and accountable in a way yeah thanks
simon i totally agree
right castle mcguff
where are you i'm right here chair thank
you much
yeah just like touching a point between
four to six in the evening
don't forget we're coming into winter
and we've actually so it's going to be
darker nights drawing in very quick
so four to six you know walking back to
car parks
and we've got an asian population within
biddeford and hoeswervy and torrenton
so i'd like to see safety of those
residents come first for me
um i'd like to point on just a comment
that kenzer inch made on the 29th of
june
saying uh we're financially sound this
country this present moment at a time is
financially sound and david hayes
alluded to that in previous meeting that
we had in on the budgetary side of
things
um a counselor says uh the day and this
rainy day uh sorry it's a rainy day um
and sometimes we've got money put aside
sorry for a rainy day
well cancer is this is a rainy day and
you don't want to spend the money
to support the wards which we you you
live within you don't represent the war
but you live within that ward
um my idea of the car barking was only
for two months
as basically trying to give the traders
something back and trying to get him on
the feet again after covid
it wasn't nothing conspiring to a
full-time free car parker in the area
because i don't agree with that
whatsoever
so you know that's a counter news in
touch on that that may be
permanent or foot in the back door not
from my side of things not no foot and
no back doors at all
it's just purely for two months a free
car working um
chair thank you very much for um
allowing me to invite me
today to um further my comments
but i i obviously i don't see it under a
committee but i i don't support the 426
and the idea was um to find the money
within the district the new homes bonus
pot
which has been a very valuable pot
within turrets since the time i first
got elected five years ago uh
50 went into top of the capital budget
or capital
the running cost of council i think i
would like mr hurst to
respond to this a moment and the other
50 was obviously projects within the
area
now the uh new homes bonus money you
know if if it's doing a village hall
you know how does that benefit a
villager and it ain't mistakes how does
that benefit the residents my award well
we all represent torridge and if it
gives people
in the villages that it's given people
in villages actually a huge boost to
their communities and that
available pot of money was fantastic
idea i fully support them
i think it was the conservative
association um jane whitaker at a time
we actually fought hard to get this
through
there's a damn good thing that she's
done and we all have to put up with this
planning mass planning and going through
with the government's bill build build
you know ended there the only way to get
yourself out of recession is to work
yourself out of it and we've got to do
that but
my idea of free car biking was use the
new homes bonus money
to support this and give something back
to our residents
um council haynes i like touching your
point please ever made and you said
about the car use
i totally agree with you we all signed
up for climate emergency
and as you can see climate emergencies
for you and all of us is going to cost
us
unlimited amount of money we don't have
a figure set aside for this money so
you need to start looking very and we
all do with you support you and how much
storage
funds should be committed to that that
become the capital programme
we have to some of these big programs
being over ages will have to be stopped
so we can tackle climate emergency if
not
you know we're not representing our
residents in that way
but um car sharing at the moment warner
where public transport with limited six
people
within movements of groups people are
really frightening to go on public
transport at the moment so the idea of
cars car sharing
obviously at the moment is should
support next to the next two months in
my idea
but i don't i don't run central
government just trying to give someone
back to community
chair thank you much for your time i
will leave you at this juncture
and thanks so much everyone's viewers on
the committee thank you
okay cheers
um okay let's go cheryl
you want to come in again yeah i was
just going to put a proposal forward
that's all right um i would suggest two
hours free parking at any time
at bridge street the manor and the pill
car parks in biddeford
sydney house and barley grave in great
torrington and the manor in holsworthy
with funding to come from the capital
programme specifically the borough
center if the grant of 400 000 is
successful from central government
and i do think that the cost estimates
should be lowered given that it's a
covered year
that would be my proposal all right okay
steve
do you just comment on that yeah we
couldn't we couldn't use the capital
funding from
um the government because that's capital
investment
and can only be used for those purposes
and obviously we don't know the time in
when
that money will be confirmed so we could
we could not get the confirmation until
um late october november we don't we
haven't got specific date for that
so if we had to wait for that as part of
the recommendation
um it may it may it might not appear and
there's no certainty of it actually
appearing so um that's again for
counselor kottel hankin to consider
um but if we had to wait for that
decision to be taken
um we may not have that in time okay
i'll just say funding from the capital
programme with the decision to be made
by full council because it have to go to
full council wouldn't it
um chain response to that so members
would then
have to review the entire capital
program
and decide which projects to take out
in order to balance the capital program
so again i wouldn't envisage that being
possible
um by october it's a piece of work
officers have already started on but as
you can
imagine because the capital program is
already
over committed we've got to take things
out of there
reprofile things to bring it back into
balance
and then would need to consider taking
other things out to fund
uh this particular uh proposal
okay what about funding from economic
development reserves
um sean i don't know if you can comment
on that obviously we used i think some
of the economic development reserves to
fund the plow
um i don't know what uh what's available
and again yeah i don't know off the top
of my head
um steve but it's it's not a massive
amount of money left in those reserves
right we wouldn't need a massive amount
of money for it
okay well we'll take it out new homes
bonus
surely um
i'm going backwards i suppose but i i
just wanted to say i don't
i wouldn't support the four till six
option uh i understand the reasoning but
i don't think that would do
the job of giving a boost to people
because i think most people
will want to go into town earlier and i
i don't think
people would think four till six is a
benefit particularly
thank you
right tony
oh thank you chair pony
yes there's a penny that uh coach from
mcgolf has left because
i'm i'm not i've never said that i'm not
supportive of two hours free parking in
in our towns i don't know where he's got
that from but still anyway i'd like to
second uh uh chris nether's uh council
letters uh
proposal in full and i think the
i think that would be a good idea and uh
i know when i um
is living around town it it always was
we always did finish uh car parking
charges at four o'clock
and it always was fairly busy in town
actually then
because uh people uh like myself it was
four to six
you get you come home from work and then
you can go out and do a bit of shopping
it doesn't
doesn't actually cost you anything
because the free the color parts was
free
and you did get a lot of people come
from work and
and go out shopping before they went
home and i think chris would agree with
that
and i i think yes i will when a
second council reverse proposal enforced
in a full chair
okay simon
thanks chap um uh i i'm afraid i i don't
agree that
um uh four to six will will
have any beneficial impact
on traders uh which is what
the authors of this motion um
wish to create um
i am going to propose as i mentioned
earlier
um a scheme where the
second hour is free at any time of the
day
whenever you buy your ticket you get a
second hour free
also first of all the cost of that will
be dramatically less because we will
still be taking for the first hour
um we will satisfy the gesture
thirdly we may find it's something that
actually we can afford to keep going
um and and it it may be that actually
this is something that could be looked
at
as a longer term thing um
to pick up on sean's terminology
specifically i recommend that
in order to increase dwell time
because it's dwell time where people
have more time
to browse the shop or to go to another
shop
rather than worrying about their ticket
expiring and rushing back
so i rec i propose that
automatically you get a second hour free
when you buy your first hour car park
uh in all of the car parks listed uh in
the
the officers report thank you
okay can i just ask us something of
counselor newton please
sorry steve it was just to ask um
councillor newton obviously made
that particular proposal were you
intending to make a proposal
of how that will be funded
well of course we can't we we really
can't
pin a figure to the wall on that one
steve
um uh but i i would
imagine that if we're taking
the 70 000 as a benchmark figure
and we've already discussed the fact
that that may not be typical for this
year
um i would imagine that we're probably
looking at a quarter of that amount
um and um
i would be i would i would say at this
stage that we take that on risk because
i don't think there's any point in
trying to
really apportion it somewhere um but
um uh if we do have to
account for it precisely um then
i i would take i would go for the the
new homes bonus on that one
yeah okay castle
and cheer can i just ask one for the
question yes they've gone um
it it's just obviously councillor
leather made his proposal and made a
recommendation to full council um
councillor newton
was your recommendation to propose that
to cnr or to full council
um i i think that any change
that we make to the cnr decision
i believe needs to go to full council
for
a final resolution otherwise
if we just bang it back to cnr this has
been to cnr
twice we're just playing ping pong with
the thing let's put it to full council
and get it resolved
it will be absolutely council news now
just wanted so we've if it we've got a
follow-up
clear proposal that's all i was sorry
thank you steve yes
that i would i would i would say
whatever we we propose or we we agree
today that it goes to full council
because um
uh otherwise it just it'll just
bounce around in in a long grass again
good
can i just jump in the mix here before i
go to counselor button
had anybody thought about just making
saturdays free
i let people go if people go it's
weekend
go shopping
okay no comments then um
yeah i've got one you the the danger
there pete is that
your car parks get cluttered cluttered
filled with residents
on on friday night yeah um so you'd
still have to have a ticket arrangement
um otherwise it'll get filled with
long-term parkers because they say
the weekend started early um and that's
treated as a as a residential parking
because i just look at shoppers of today
you know i mean shopping
a few years ago you used to go friday
off friday afternoon friday evening
saturday morning
you know but now we're thinking that we
can give two hours
free parking at any time
richard okay you froze again then so um
richard sorry yeah
it was just to say mr chairman that i'd
be happy to second council newton's
proposal of the
basic um you know by one hour and one
hour free
okay i could say check that i just come
in briefly
um as stacy's just reminded me and
advised that if members of the committee
or if the committee
make a recommendation um that's
different
to the cnr decision then it has to be
reported back to cnr and not
straight to full council that's what's
required in the constitution
so the two the two proposals we've
currently got
as they are different to the um original
recommendation
would have to be reported back to cnr
so basically steve if they'll have to go
back to cnr because
the way this this this uh this
conversation have been going
it's not going to be what what cnr
approved
is it so it's going to have to go back
to cnr stacy
so the two proposals you have yes that's
what i understand in stacy
if stacy's uh probably there
yes yeah um the reason being
and i know just from reading the report
it did say
recommendation regarding whether it'll
go to cnr or full council
the reason for that is because we we
weren't sure what decision members would
make today now if a decision
was made that affects the budget as a
whole that's a full council decision
because it's full council that set the
budget for the council
but full council have delegated their
powers in relation to land and finance
to cnr
cnr have made this decision and any
decision that ons
reached today would be a recommendation
back to cnr to
that's emotions that's your comments and
that's what you're
um asking them to consider but it is cnr
that have the power in this council
to to make decisions in relation to land
and finance so
i don't think we can override that and
go to go to full council it would be
full council if it's affecting the
overall budget
and i think that's why um in the office
of report
we've tried to put in um ways by which
this can be achieved within the current
budget but if it
a decision isn't made as to how to fund
it and it isn't within our current
budget that's when
it goes back to full council and i think
that's the confusion
okay
i i i'm torn anyway sean
you want you've got your hand up mate
yeah yes very very
very very briefly i don't know whether
it's helpful in terms of budgeting for
any
alternative proposals so if we come back
to councillor newton's
suggestion in the previous report
we've done um so this is the report
that's appended
the 17th of august one page nine we put
out a table
for the cost of one hour cost of two
hours over
those two months now so your first hour
is is approximately 40
of the 70 odd thousand pound total cost
yeah so if we look if we were looking to
budget for cancer
newton's proposal it would be somewhere
in the region of 40 to 45
of the 74 or whatever it is identified
in the report there
so that would give us an indication of
what we're looking at numbers were
and so if i think councillor newton's
said something about it coming out of
the new homes bonus
using the the new homes bonus
am i right i i would i i would have
thought so but
that's just sean can we translate that
into a financial figure
you said what 40 percent is that what
you said
yes so so so 40 of the the 70
right so so in the in today's report
we've identified and i you know i i get
uh councillor cotterhunken's point that
she doesn't think that this
is um an accurate figure it's
it's as good as we can do really i mean
anything else is complete guesswork this
is based on last year
so 40 if you worked out 40 of 72 and a
half thousand pounds
you probably get to the figure that we
might need to somewhere in the region of
it
it's a best guess it's about 30 000
is is the region we're talking about
right
so that that for that that could come
out of the new homes bonus
okay if you yes if you looked at the
table again on
page five indicating
resources available 93 000 you could
take 30 000
out of that and still be left uh with 63
000. fine i'd still be left to give the
36 councils their extra thousand pound
back
that's right shame that's fine that's
fine
in that case then uh we've got two
proposals now
okay you'll need to check if if members
are
need to change their proposals obviously
you've got two proposals yes
it's got two hands up and this is going
to be the last two ones we're going to
sort the
three hands up okay
david early all right
i've listened to this it's a excellent
debate i'm pleased it's been called in
um the council of grant i mean i believe
when the money was uh
taken away at the beginning of the
pandemic we were more or less assured i
believe
that the money would be returned what
was left of it at the end of the
pandemic and we seem to be getting
towards that stage now
yeah so i think that those grants should
come back
two counts it does a good job
simon's point now the first hour we paid
for the first hour
second now of three that's something i
mentioned
a few weeks ago another meeting because
i think that's the way to go
at least to get income for the first
time which is the main part
and if you want to be uh magnanimous and
give the members the public something
back
the second hour is free this is the
situation that works
has worked pretty well in cornwall i've
been to car parks down there well that's
that's the situation
so at least there's an income yeah
yeah and i also listened um to what was
said
where are we uh
okay forget that when i
questioned um examples given to
councillors regarding free parking
elsewhere
i asked for examples and council jones
gave an example of dudley
it was pointed out that dudley was
stopping their free parking a week or so
after this
example was given but i took it further
than that i actually wrote
to the leader of dudley council uh
councillor patrick harley
and asked him if it had any effect
having the free car parking
the report i got back basically said no
it's difficult to say yes it had but in
essence no
and i also noticed mr harper had looked
at evidence and no evidence can be found
that free parking actually works
i think people will be prepared to pay
to park
anywhere you like provided there's
something there to attract them
if there's nothing there to attract them
they won't go
simple as that i know i'm the same i
spoke to someone the other day they talk
about going to exeter
it's a long way to go but they go there
they pay to park because there's
attraction
of things they want to want to see also
note
i think councillor james mentioned was
it mid devon east devon
they they said uh it's not worth the
bother for her to actually go for free
parking
um and as i say people will travel to
pay and park
as for climate change we talk about um
money
needed by this council it was brought up
by councillor haynes or sorry by council
mcguff
that more money will be needed to sort
out things
this council will need to do regard to
climate change we are not a rich council
by any means we've been told
that money running out within a couple
of years we'll be in more of a problem
where'd you get the money from so really
to satisfy
both camps uh i think pay first hour
free for the second hour everybody would
then i think be happy
i'd be a lot happier we're not giving
away money that we can all afford to do
and those that want free parking may
well see it as ok
step in the right direction because
we're giving something back
to the people thank you chair okay david
cheryl unless you you're going to be the
last
uh but okay
i was wondering if councillor newton
would consider
um with where the funding comes from
whether
it could come from the unspent council
of grants from last year
because that's not affecting the council
grants for this year and that's 25 000
and then is it 30 in total so an extra
five could
come from the new homes bonus so then
there would still be some new homes
bonus money left over
and maybe the council could look at the
new homes bonus applications that didn't
hear back
and whether we could still give some of
that funding to them that they've missed
out on
would counselor newton be happy to sort
of amend where the funding came from
okay can i just clarify something just
before counselor newton responds
yeah um it's 40 000 is the cost so
on page nine the table indicates the i
thought it was forty percent of the
seventies yeah sorry it's forty percent
income so it's the so if you look at the
table on page
nine my apologies it might misunderstood
standing um so so it's thirty thousand
that we gain so it's 40 000 that you
lose for the second hour
it's just 30 000 income for the first
hour and 40 000 income for the second
hour so it's 40 000
that would have to be funded right okay
i thought
40 sean was saying it was 40
for the first hour so it'd be 40 of the
yeah so you get 40 40 income for the
first hour so you lose 60 percent
what what if we just did
buy one get one free for the first two
hours
in every car park every day
that was what councilman newton proposed
wasn't it yeah that's
yeah just to jump in chair if i can yeah
that
that's what my proposal is i i'm
steve you're presumably you're you're
back on the table at page nine of the
of the supporting uh report um
where you are in the second
um table you are
working out the difference between one
hour and two hours is that right
that's right so 000 of the 72
000 is the kind of 40 so
so the income from the first hour is the
30 000
so you're losing which is about 40
percent and you're losing 60
so that's where the 40 000 comes from so
in terms
of fund funding it as i said on
on page five you've got 93 000 so if you
took
40 000 from that you'd have 53 left
which would enable 36 to go back to
member grants and he would leave a small
balance of
18 000 yeah yeah and with that steve
let's
let's slightly
put a bit of subjectivity into this
rather than purely
objectivity please um and so
the the baseline figure we're not
confident about
um it's last year's figure but there's
too much change going on for this year
and therefore we we reckon that the the
baseline figure
is likely to be less than last year's
figure
so uh and i reckon that's a reasonable
assumption
that let's say 72 000 pounds is last
year
let's say 60 000 pounds for this year
um because of the different
circumstances
if that's the case i i i i
agree that um
we take it and i propose that we take it
as the balance of member grants that
were brought forward from last year
so that's 25k um and
um that is topped up um
from the new hubs bonus from the new
homes bonus
uh can somebody just if we said a top
line figure of 60k
how much 36 000 okay
so we're talking at um
taking 10 000 then from the new homes
bonus
um and and all of the
claw back from last year's member grant
uh submission so we're
we're we're keeping um
member grant full for this year
okay anybody else
i mean me personally i don't agree with
any of it i don't think we should be
giving free parking but
obviously i don't think if i put up that
proposal there
it would gain any weight at all yeah can
i just
can i just mention at the moment our car
parks at present
are busier than they've ever been this
time of the day
chris you don't have to remind me i or
tell me i've i've
actually been i've had to have a snoop
unless they're fantastically busy let's
just answer counselor newton i don't
think you can pre-suppose that
october and november are going to be
less than last year i think that
they'll be equivalent if not more than
last year because there's one
possibility
but we'll have to just wait and see on
that yeah not if we go into lockdown
yeah well i'm sure we'll go into luck
now
uh but that's another thing we're not
discussing lockdown
cheryl we we're just cutting out are we
going to get a bit of free parking
and make ourselves
chair could i just can i oh god it's
frozen
can i just come in steve has mentioned
altering altering the and and stacy
meant it's got to
go back to cnr yeah i still want to
maintain
that we have the the period of four
o'clock until six
three
right but can i just please
so so i want with councillor inches
agreement because he seconded this
so still four till six o'clock for those
two months
but that it does go back to cnr and that
the funding for this comes from
a combination of member grants and new
homes boldness
and but and by then by then at cnr um
sean carney have had the chance to look
at the
what we collect from the car parks
between four and six o'clock
and come to a realistic figure what
that's like to cost
i think it'd be a lot less than
councillor newton's proposal to be
honest
okay well who proposed first anyway i
think it was your proposal
let's let's recap the proposal council
leaders proposal was i think he you put
that
up first and then and and councilor
newton put his
second so where's sandra sandrick
did you make me notice what the proposal
is sorry steve
you need to confirm if councillor inches
will in uh
his original proposal and yes councillor
leather's proposal was first
so we would consider that one vote on
that one in the first instance
tony yep is that that's all okay in me
chair is that thing
you're okay with that yes okay
uh and do we want to clarify exactly
what the proposal is okay shall i just
uh read it out and counsel allah can
indicate then whether
uh i'm accurate um so it's for
a car free car park in between the hours
of four
and six um in all the car parks in the
table
in the report uh that recommendation to
go back to cnr
and to be funded from a combination
of member grants and the balance to come
from
um new homes bonus that's the member
that remembers that money
the chair's frozen again
yeah sorry steve i i keep i keep
freezing that that is the money
the 25 000 uh from the members grants
from last year
that wasn't used i believe so
yeah and to be talked up from the new
homes bonus and
it's still for the period of october and
november
yeah that's fine okay so
do we need to have simon's on the
[ __ ]
chair yeah sorry
um councillor newton's proposal is there
but it was amended um can we get
councillor abouting's
approval please as you second the motion
okay
richard yes yeah oh yes that's fine
that's okay yeah
okay okay so just just for clarification
stacy do we go
now with councillor letters first
and then councillor newton's second
yes chair we'll take them in the order
they came came in so councilman levers
first and then councillor newton's
okay right sandra
go to the vote please please
everybody please be ready to vote okay
council aboutton
sorry mr dengate against
councillor gab against
langford against
councillor leather for
councillor newton against
councillor watson i'm
abstain god's truth
that the vote their chair was three
four seven against and
one abstention right okay
that motion is lost okay we go to to
to simon's now then okay i've just got a
question what happens if neither are
approved
what happens to the motion then
you see what happens to the motion the
cnr decision will
will remain so so ons today will make
the purposes of these promotions is to
make recommendations back to ons
sorry back to cnr so if all motions fail
then the cnr
one will remain okay thank you
okay sandra we'll text simon's now
okay thank you chair councillor bounton
four
councillor coddle honking well i'd like
to stick with the previous decision so
against
uh mr dengate or
cancer club for
councillor haims again
mr harper or
cancer inch for
councillor langford for
pennsylvania oh no councillor leather
poor chancellor newton
and cancer watson four
that's nine four and two against chair
okay
so that that recommendation goes to cnr
okay brand it goes again
sorry i said round it goes again
well that that's democracy i'm sorry
you know you have to grin and bear it i
know i know it's difficult
no more nobody got more frustrated with
council work than me
cracking yeah okay could we possibly
hear
what's been resolved again yes
uh sandra would you read it out please
oh steve um yeah i
can do it um so the the pro
what was being recommended is one hour
paid and the second hour free in
all of the the car parks uh listed
on page four for october and
november um and to be funded from
um the balance of member grants and from
the new homes bonus brought forward from
1920
right okay thank you chair
okay everybody well i know obviously i
was going to see everybody happy but
everybody can't be happy
but anyway we'll get on now we've we've
finished uh
exclusion of the public with we haven't
got any
so i gonna call this meeting closed
and welcome you all back on the 29th
when we've got
two more of these to do so